[Music]
foreign
book in history no volume ever written
has been more loved and quoted and its
words sometimes simple and sometimes
mysterious should always be studied
carefully it is the Bible the word of
God welcome to Bible answers live
providing accurate and practical answers
to all your Bible questions
our phone lines are open if you have a
Bible related question give us a call
now at 800 God says that's
800-463-7297 now here's your host from
amazing facts International Pastor Doug
Batchelor
Hello friends would you like to hear an
amazing fact
in 2019 contractors in North Yorkshire
England were renovating someone's
kitchen
after prying up the old wooden
floorboards and breaking through six
inches of concrete they unearth a glazed
cup similar in size to a soda can in and
around the cup they found 260 gold coins
dating between 1610 and 1727.
the coins were likely hidden there by
Joseph and Sarah Fernley Masters a
wealthy Merchant couple that once lived
in the house and evidently didn't have
much faith in the local banks of their
day
the estimated value of the treasure is
more than two hundred and ninety
thousand dollars
which should help pay for the remodeled
kitchen and I don't know what you think
Pastor Austin they'll have some left
over to bury under the floor that's
right maybe for the next person who buys
the house but you think of all of the
hard work that they put into trying to
gather this treasure and then they bury
it and evidently they didn't pass it on
to their to their children or they die
tragically they forgot about it yeah
many years later somebody uncovers it
while they're remodeling the kitchen it
almost seems a waste if they could have
used it for uh the benefit of others at
that time wouldn't that have been better
than just bearing it yeah oh yeah it's
sad when you know the people they they
hoard money and they think they've got
uh they're making at least they don't
pass it on to their their heirs or
something you know give it to a
foundation but this got buried and
discovered centuries later by strangers
and I think there's actually proverb
that talks about that and Jesus tells us
in Luke chapter 12 verse 16 he spoke
this Parable to them saying the ground
of a certain rich man yielded
plentifully and he thought within
himself saying what shall I do since I
have no room to store all my crops he
thought a little bit and then he said
this is what I'll do I'll pull down my
Barns and I'll build greater and they're
all store all my crops and my goods and
I'll say to my soul soul you have many
Goods laid up for many years take your
ease eat drink and be merry
but God said to him fool this night your
soul will be required of you then whose
will those things be for which you have
provided
so is he lays up treasure for himself
and is not rich towards God yeah it's an
amazing Parable here you have this
person who is being blessed and they
think well I'm going to hold all of
these blessings to myself but in reality
it would have been better if he used it
to build up the kingdom of heaven I'm
reminded of the other verse Pastor Doug
that says lay up for yourselves not
treasure on Earth but rather in heaven
and where your treasure is that's where
your heart will be also so the principle
that we find in the Bible is that there
is an investment that Believers can be
involved in that actually earns
dividends throughout eternity we can lay
up treasury in heaven and you know it is
true and I don't want to sound like a
Prosperity preacher but there is some
truth to the the scripture the principle
that with what measure you meet it'll be
measured to you and and Jesus tells us
that if we're generous that uh men will
Heap into your bosom people will be
generous with you God says if you prove
him test him when it comes to tithe and
offering he says see if I don't open for
you the windows of Heaven so even in
this life it's more blessed to give than
receive because it seems like blessings
Ricochet they come back absolutely you
know a lot of people are wondering what
are the biblical principles for money as
you mentioned Pastor Doug there's some
confusion even the Christian world as to
how we ought to use our resources
amazing facts as a study guide It's
called In God We Trust And it deals with
the subject of money you'll be surprised
Jesus said quite a bit about finances
and how we ought to use money we'll be
happy to send this to anyone who calls
and asks the number is
800-835-6747 that is our resource phone
line you can ask for off number 135 or
you can ask for the study guide by name
it's called In God We Trust we'll send
that to anyone in North America if
you're listening outside of North
America we encourage you to go to our
Amazing Facts website just
amazingfacts.org and you'll be able to
read the study guide right there online
of course maybe that's a good time pass
it out for us to welcome those who are
listening across the country and around
the world for those of you who might not
know this is a radio program we're
broadcasting on a number of land-based
stations also on satellite radio but
we're also a TV program now and we are
broadcasting live at amazing facts TV
we're also streaming this live on the
internet Doug Batchelor Facebook page
the amazing facts Facebook page so I'm
going to welcome all of those who are
tuned in and part of our program if you
have a Bible related question the phone
line to call is
800-463-7297 that's
800-463-7297 and if you're watching this
on the Internet or you're watching it on
one of the networks and I think we've
rebroadcasting pasadagon on some other
networks through ebn hope TV so I saw
the rebroadcast from last week this week
on AF TV so they're they're keeping up
with it it's also going out right now
here it's going out on Hope Channel as
well so we're excited yeah absolutely
all right if you have a question again
800-463-7297 before we go to the phone
lines let's start with the word of
Prayer
dear father once again we are grateful
for this opportunity to be able to open
your word and study Lord there is power
in your word so we're going to ask your
blessing upon the program this evening
be with us here in the studio and we ask
a special blessing also on those who are
listening wherever they might be we ask
us in Jesus name amen amen all right I
think we're ready for our first call of
this evening we've got Patrick and he's
calling from Canada Patrick you're on
the air
good evening pastors good evening I have
a question thank you I have a question
um in regards to Ezekiel chapter 4 verse
9. I like to find out if that is has any
relations to the Ezekiel bread that is
sold today
and
um verse 12. if that has any
relationship to do with verse 9
. yeah well there some people have taken
the verses here in Ezekiel 4 and let me
read it for our friends that are
listening we always want to remember
that ninety percent of the people
listening to the program they can't
maybe look it up right at the moment but
it says here in Ezekiel verse 9 and this
is a prophecy that came to the the
prophet Ezekiel from the Lord also take
for yourself wheat barley beans lentils
Millet and spelled put them in one
vessel make bread of them for yourself
during the number of the days that you
lie on your side 390 days you shall eat
it and it shall be your food you shall
eat by weight 20 shekels a day from the
time that you shall eat it you shall
also drink water my measure 1 6 of a hen
from the time that you shall drink and
you'll eat it as barley cakes and bake
it using the fuel of human waste in
their sight
now that certainly would not be a good
recipe for uh health conscious people to
follow I think God is telling Ezekiel by
living out this Parable it was
describing the period of time that the
people in Israel and Judea that remain
behind were going to be experiencing
some famine and uh you know they were
taking everything they could find and
putting it in their bread now people
have made I've eaten Ezekiel Bread
before they've made some good tasting
bread by combining these different
elements
when Ezekiel protests he says lord I
can't bake this over human waste that's
unclean I'm a priest I've never done
anything unclean God says well I'm going
to let you use cow dung instead and you
know for ages people have actually
cooked on Buffalo chips and animal dung
and you've probably seen it in Africa so
that was not that uncommon but this is a
parable that Ezekiel was living out
talking about the hardship that God's
people were going to go through it's not
necessarily a recipe for health bread
that's right and if you the context that
you mentioned they passed the dog they
were making bread out of whatever they
could find typically in the Bible the
best kind of bread was bread made from
wheat but here in this situation wheat
was hard to come by and so they were
using some wheat but they were mixing
whatever they could barley was usually
for the animals right right that's
prophecy and Revelation says the penny
was it a measure of barley for a penny
it's talking about time of famine that's
right yeah shortness well thank you for
your call Patrick we hope that helped
and there is as mentioned there is a
bread that it's called Ezekiel bread and
I don't know if they use every single
one of these items listed here but it is
pretty good so Thomas listening in
Minnesota Thomas welcome to the program
you're on the air yeah having trouble
explaining myself let me explain now
basically speaking I ran across
something let's see we have something in
my Roku Network called special projects
prophecy alert let me explain they
explained some activity on Pope Francis
one of which was of course trying to
unify all the Christians together have a
one world religion secondly we had him
go to the Temple Mount and try to
negotiate peace with the Palestinians
now according to this thing now the
reference I'm making here the prophecy
alert is called special Prophet projects
prophecy alert three of eight
so uh at least the article said that was
a very significant and in fact
the events that were occurring were
actually uh they cited the second
Thessalonians chapter four one to four
so any significance to that okay thank
you let's go to the verse that you
mentioned second Thessalonians chapter
four and let's do a verse you said
second Thessalonians chapter four I
think the second second Thessalonians
chapter two right chapter two verses one
through four yeah yeah now Brethren
concerning the coming of our Lord Jesus
Christ and our gathering together to him
we ask you not to be soon shaken in mind
or troubled either by Spirit or by word
or by letter from us as though the day
of the Lord had come Paul is telling the
Thessalonians he says there's a lot of
excitement that the day of Lord had
already come
and he said let no one deceive you by
any means for that day will not come
unless there is a falling away that
comes first in the man of sin is
revealed the Son of Perdition who
opposes and exalts himself above all
that is called God or worshiped so that
he sits as God in the temple of God
showing himself that he is god so let's
talk about that verse uh you know it's
hard for me to comment on what you may
have seen at a at a website somewhere
but um most Protestants I mean like well
Luther and Spurgeon and Wesley and many
others Calvin and
John Knox they identified this verse the
man of sin they believe was the pope
they believed it was a a religious
leader that was putting himself in a
place to be worshiped putting himself
over the temple of God now keep in mind
one of the terms for the church is the
body of Christ Jesus said we are living
stones Christ had destroyed this Temple
made with hands in three days I will
make one without hands he's talking
about his body which is the church
and so Paul says what don't you know
that ye are the temple of God meaning
collectively we are the temple so they
understood that for the pope to say I am
in charge of the church where Jesus
really never assigned any One Pastor or
Apostle to be over everything you see it
bouncing between Paul and Peter and
James in the New Testament
um they said that was
um
that was the Antichrist behavior and
it's interesting to know that the first
person who called the office of Pope
Antichrist was a pope that's right
that's Pope Gregory it was there was
quite a fight that went on between well
two individuals claimed to be Pope and
they went back and forth accusing one
another of being the Antichrist that's
right and of course that was during the
time Marco Polo yeah he was trying to
get the missionaries and they were
fighting among themselves calling each
other Antichrist that's right and then
it occurred later on during the time of
the Reformation yeah where the reform is
even pointed that out so it's happened
more than once where there was different
individuals vying for power so what's
happening now and based on the question
that uh Josiah or Thomas rather is
asking is that um
since the Protestant churches all came
out of the Catholic church in succeeding
Generations that animosity has
dissipated and the pope is calling
Protestants to reunite again and we are
seeing a big movement towards that Pope
Francis is he's reached out to the
Russian Orthodox and the Greek Orthodox
and the Coptic church leaders and and
charismatics in North America have gone
to meet with the Pope and he's saying
look the most important thing is let's
just be one and you know it sounds
beautiful but it doesn't mean you
sacrificed doctrinal Truth for the sake
of unity and so that's the thing we need
to be careful about all right thanks
Nicole uh Thomas we've got uh Josiah
listening as well Josiah listening from
New York welcome to the program
yes good evening well um just to
ask to what should you said Okay
um with the previous um caller
so Archie was all
Protestant don't you all go back to the
Catholic Church lucky States
yeah well most Protestants uh most
Protestant denominations were kind of
drawn out of the Catholic church and
they retained maybe even some of the
Theology and their doctrines some of the
traditions of the church too now there
have been people since then since the
Protestant Reformation that came from
Total paganism I'm one of them I didn't
really come from a Christian Church I
read the Bible
and just said I'm going to go by the
Bible so there's a lot of people that
have just kind of come into the truth or
come to the Lord directly from the word
but several denominations either broke
away from the Catholic church or they
broke away from breakaways which is why
you've got so many divisions of
methodists and Presbyterians and
Baptists and Christians in the world
today
but am I answering your question Jerry
oh that's that's not the question I just
wanted to add to what he was asking but
okay
dealing with the same chapter though
okay second test second Thessalonians
um yeah you read one two four
um can you continue reading to eight
please all right let me start with verse
five
do you not remember that when I was
still with you I told you these things
and now you know what is restraining
that he may be revealed in his own time
for the mystery of lawlessness called in
the King James the mystery of iniquity
is already at work only he who now
restrains will do so until he is taken
out of the way then that Lawless one
will be revealed whom the Lord will
consume with the breath of his mouth and
Destroy where the brightness of his
coming
so that's the verse I think you're
talking about right that's one through
it I'm talking about it's it's uh verse
8 and
and verse three verse 3 said uh let no
man deceive you by any means for that
day shall not come except they come a
following away but in that man of sin
they reveal the Son of Perdition but
when you go when you go to verse 8 then
it say it and then shall the wicked be
revealed whom the Lord shall consume
with it with the spirit of his mask so
who is that Wicked what can you go in
the Bible because I I I've done some
research and I see
who the Bible who who does the Bible
says is the wicked okay well first of
all the ultimate Wicked one is the devil
I mean you don't you don't find anybody
that is uh supervising the devil in
wickedness so he would be the supreme
power behind the other powers but the
devil has been manipulating what is
called the beast power through history
it receives a deadly wound and the
deadly wound is healed and uh like I
said the Protestants understand that
that was the papacy that became a
persecuting power during the time of the
Inquisition and uh it's kind of coming
back in on the stage now they they've
got a seat in the United Nations no
other church does that's right and it's
used different names are used here in
the new King James that I have it refers
to the Lawless one and then it goes on
and it talks about the Son of Perdition
and it's talking about this one who he's
doing um with all unrighteous deception
amongst those who perish uh so it's the
same power that's been referred to we're
not talking specifically about one
individual we're talking about a
position of office uh because the papal
position has lasted for almost 2 000
years so yeah talking about that that
system or that that power and it's got
different names Lawless is interesting
that he's setting aside the law of God
for man-made law or human tradition so
it's one of the identifying marks you
know for the last two people who've
called in we have a study guide that's
called who is the Antichrist and we
encourage them to request that we'll
send it to them or anyone listening for
free absolutely the number to call is
800-463 actually that is the phone line
to call if you have a question the free
offer number is
800-835-6747 and you can ask for that
study guide it's simply called who is
the Antichrist and it'll get into all of
the various Bible verses both here in
second Thessalonians but also some of
the prophecies in Revelation and Daniel
the number again is
800-835-6747 you can ask for the study
guide who is the Antichrist next call
that we have is Leola listening from
Massachusetts Leola welcome to the
program
good evening how are you fine thanks for
calling and your question
my question is
um more for my son what does the Bible
say about attending prom or school
dances is it allowed
yeah well that would uh of course depend
upon the the nature of that particular
school and what they're doing you know
there are some Christian schools that
will have graduation Galas that are
probably innocent enough uh and you know
a lot of young people Revel in the idea
of dressing up a little bit and and
getting together with classmates and I
think those social interactions
important for kids during that time in
their life then you can have some
schools that are pretty Pagan where
those things turn into a you know a
pretty
um
serious Rock concert you know things get
out of hand and the folks are spiking
the punch and you know that's and the
dancing is uh it's pretty sexually
suggestive so it would really depend
Lola uh you would have to evaluate the
school and what their standards are and
how well things are chaperoned and the
typical worldly dancing is not something
I pictured Jesus doing
but um
you know I've actually I've seen some
Christian socials where they had these
these Galas where the kids got together
and they dressed up and it was all well
supervised and they had a special meal
and and it was a memorable occasion for
the kids they all took pictures and and
they look at them for years and see how
funny they dress back then that's right
all right well thanks for your call
we've got Jerry listening in Texas Jerry
welcome to the program
hey Pastor hi uh just one additional
note I've been to Doug's Church in
Shiprock anyway my whole question it was
good they remembered them my connects my
question tonight I want to refer to
Revelation 8 17 where it says there's
silence in heaven
for one half hour now there is no verse
17 in Revelation 8. but uh 17 I thought
uh 17. uh eight verse one silence in
heaven about it yeah okay
oh that thing
all right so that's that's what you want
to know about Spirit uh the Holy Spirit
and our Guardian Angels don't leave us
until they appear in the second coming
and they join Jesus
because the guardian angels are still
with us during the time of probation
right well yeah it is true that uh you
know God has Angels on the earth
watching over his people there's no
doubt about that if they left us for a
minute we'd be in in a lot of trouble
but Revelations talking about things
going quiet in heaven and we believe
that's because heaven has been vacated
Michael is stood up judgment is over
probation is closed and Christ and his
angels come to the Earth
the Bible says when Jesus comes all the
Holy Angels are with him and that would
include our Guardian Angels but that's
here on Earth Heaven is now quiet
because it's been vacated as they come
to our resurrect and to retrieve the
redeemed
and anyone who might remain in heaven
God the father or any of the other
Angelic beings their focus is going to
be What's Happening Here on the earth
because Christ is coming all the angels
are coming with him so when we read
about this half an hour it's kind of
interesting Pastor Doug what is the half
an hour I know we're talking about
prophetic time here yeah well you know
in Bible prophecy most Scholars agree
that you apply a principle where a day
equals a year for instance when God told
the children of Israel for every day
that the spies looked at the promised
land they will wander a year for each
day and it turns from 40 days to 40
years
It also says that in Ezekiel 4 6 Jesus
said tell Herod that I will teach and do
cures and cast out Devils today tomorrow
and the third day I will be perfected
Jesus did not Minister for three more
days he ministered for three more years
so even Jesus used that principle in a
prophecy so if a day equals a year in
Prophecy
and
an hour is 124th of a day
then one hour using a day for a year is
15 days
and uh half an hour would be half of 15
which is seven because it says about the
space of half an hour and so of course
that's a great Bible number you find all
through Revelation there's more sevens
than any other number this is the period
of time that passes when there's silence
when Christ comes and we don't know how
much time he spends coming and how much
time he spends going back but at least
they're they're gone during that
procession
okay you know we do have a study guide
that talks about the second coming of
Christ and it's called ultimate
deliverance and we'll be happy to send
this to anyone who calls and asks the
number to call these
800-835-6747 and just ask for the study
guide It's All About the second coming
it's called ultimate Deliverance I'm
gonna be happy to send it to anyone here
in North America we have machine
listening in California machine welcome
to the program
hello hi thanks for calling
um hi um I'm a new Christian my question
is how do I
um devote myself every morning put on
the whole armor of God and ask for the
Holy Spirit
to be with me throughout my day how do I
do that great question one of the most
important it's one thing when we come to
the Lord and anybody can do that by just
turning to God and asking him to come
into their lives repenting of their sins
and saying Lord I'm willing to follow
you I'll take up my cross and I'll
follow you but what does it mean when it
says to Die daily to deny yourself
and basically in your devotions uh
there's there's three things you do
to stay healthy as a Christian
you breathe
you eat and you exercise and then of
course you do those things consistently
in the Holy place of the temple there
were three articles of furniture now you
got the holy of holies there's one thing
in there that's the Ark of the Covenant
the holy Place had the light
it had the table of bread it had the
altar of incense the incense represents
prayer the Bible says that in Revelation
the instances of prayers of the Saints
the bread represented the word of God
man doesn't live by bread alone Jesus
said but by every word
and then the
um
the light represents witnessing Jesus
said let your light so shine that men
may see your good works and glorify God
we want to let our light shine and so
every day we should spend time I do
every morning I read my Bible I get on
my knees I pray of course you pray all
through the day but formally talk to the
Lord commit your way to the Lord and
then look for opportunities to be his
witness through the the ups and downs of
life every day you have opportunities to
witness for the Lord if you ask him the
holy spirit will give you those
opportunities you'll be tempted you'll
have lots of opportunity to deny
yourself
holy spirit will say don't say that or
you should say this or don't look at
that or you should look at this and all
through the day you've got a don't eat
that or don't eat it yet so you've
always got the Holy Spirit guiding you
and as you listen to that and you're
controlled by the spirit and not by the
flesh you become more like Christ and
you that's what it means to walk with
God
so that's a quick overview Messin I hope
that helps a little bit and you know we
have a study guide I think you'd enjoy
and it's the first in the series of the
amazing facts Bible study guides is
there anything left you can trust and I
think you'd appreciate that I also
thought of another yeah offer that
Maxine might enjoy it's called the armor
of God it's a little book we're not
talking about the armor of God how do we
put on the armor of God so two free
office so anyone who calls and asks you
can ask for the book called the armor of
God and then also ask for anything left
you can trust it's number one in our
Bible study series we'll be happy to
send it to anyone who calls and asks the
number again is
800-835-6747 we don't have time to take
another call before the break but we
might want to mention to folks that
you're going to be heading somewhere
tomorrow not too far away but it is a
another country yes well for any of our
friends that keep up with amazing facts
they probably have heard Pastor Carlos
Munoz he sat at this table before
and he and I are going to Mexico City
one of the biggest cities in the world
and we'll be doing some evangelism there
for the next two weeks looking forward
to that it's also going to be airing the
second week is going to be on three
three ABN Latino their television
station now friends you hear the music
we're not done we're just taking a break
couldn't get a drink of water and you
can then text your friends tell them to
tune in for the second half the Bible
answers live we'll be back
stay tuned Bible answers live will
return shortly
[Music]
life can be overwhelming where can an
ongo woman find quality time with God
the new amazing Treasures of Faith box
set from amazing facts empowers your
devotional life with inspiring resources
that will bring lasting peace into your
busy life this beautifully designed box
set by women for women comes with a 31
day devotional recipe and scripture
cards and special messages from Pastor
Doug and Karen Batchelor get your
amazing Treasures of Faith box set today
just call
800-538-7275 or visit afbooks
hi friends Pastor Doug Batchelor we are
very excited to be celebrating the
50-year anniversary of the amazing facts
Bible school for 50 years now we've seen
tens of thousands of people go through
this study course and their lives have
been absolutely transformed so I'm here
with Tammy Stevenson who is the amazing
facts Bible School supervisor Tammy what
are some of the different courses that
are offered in the series in the
correspondence course we offer two main
studies at Children's and and adults and
it's both in Spanish and English on an
online course we have two adult studies
and we have a children's study and
they're in a variety of different
languages now does a person need to be
very familiar with the Bible to go
through the course or can anybody do it
no anybody can do it it's very basic
starts out very basic and gets more
advanced as you go through how do we see
the lessons transforming people's lives
our graduating students have shared with
us that it has helped them to grow
spiritually in the relationship Jesus
Christ and it has also empowered them to
witness in their communities in their
workplace and within their family
members so Tammy if a person is now
curious and they want to go through the
Bible study course how do they do that
all they have to do is go to
amazingbiblestudies.com and enroll
praise God and thank you friends for
supplying the resources to make this
Bible School available for free for 50
years
you're listening to Bible answers live
where every question answered provides a
clearer picture of God and his plan to
save you so what are you waiting for get
practical answers about the good book
for a better life today
if you have a question about the Bible
or living the Christian Life call us now
at 800 God says that's
800-463-7297 now let's rejoin our hosts
for more Bible answers live
welcome back listening friends to Bible
answers live some have been with us
along the way and others are joining us
this is a live International Bible study
program and you can join us by calling
in with your Bible questions and the
number is
800-463-7297 that's 800 God says and
we're streaming on Facebook it's on the
amazing facts Facebook page it's on the
Doug Batchelor Facebook page I think
it's on YouTube and a number of outlets
we'd love to hear your Bible questions
my name is Doug Batchelor my name is
John Ross and we've got Rita listening
from Indiana Rita welcome to the program
thank you thank you for taking my call
yes
um what I want to know is it seems like
I think it's in John 8. there's a couple
of times where Jesus was going to be
stoned and he managed to slip away from
the crowd
and and then when he walked on water to
see the disciples they didn't recognize
him at first and they didn't recognize
him until he told Peter to come out and
come to him and then when he was at
Gethsemane Judas had arranged a signal
with the people that were coming to
arrest Jesus so they would know who
Jesus was
now I don't understand
why no one could figure out who he was
or where he was if there was a crowd of
people that were going to Stone him
wouldn't you think several of them would
see him and say there he is let's get
him or wouldn't you think the disciples
would know him on the water or wouldn't
the people that were going to arrest him
I mean everybody knew who Jesus was by
then but they had to have a signal from
Judas so I'm wondering do we all see
Jesus in a different way are you seeing
a blonde blue-eyed Jesus and I'm seeing
a brown-haired brown-eyed Jesus and we
don't all recognize him and that's why
we he can slip away all right let me
jump in there that that's uh interesting
assortment of stories you have there now
when they were going to Stone Jesus and
he passed through their midst there's
times in the Bible where Elisha blinded
an army so they could not see him so I
think that God's angels blinded the ones
who are going to uh estonium so that's
what happened I believe in that case is
that God just protected him when the
disciples did not recognize him on the
water when he's walking in water that's
at night during a storm and you know
maybe in the flash of lightning they see
this figure walking towards them they
didn't know who it was at first then you
know he calls out through the rain and
the waves says it's me and Peter says
Lord if it's you let me come to you that
was just the obscurity of the the rain
and the storm and the Darkness I think
when he uh Rose or when Judas went to
arrest him you're talking about deep
into the night they're they're in this
garden they're coming with torches it is
true they had no photographs back then
and so when they said Jesus Wanted Dead
or Alive
they didn't have his picture on
telephone poles on a poster anywhere
he looked like a normal person and
that's why they said Judas you do
recognize him you know what he looks
like you go up and kiss him on the cheek
so we'll know which one to arrest
because Christ often traveled with his
Apostles and sometimes additional
disciples it says there was the apostles
and the women that followed him and so
Judas clearly knew who he was so I think
that Jesus did have a real form and
everybody knew what he looked like the
ones who knew him
but not having photographs and so much
of what they knew about Jesus was
through the stories others were hearing
even Herod heard about him and he said I
want to see him so they didn't know what
he looked like
perhaps another reason why they had
Judas lead them to Jesus is Judas knew
what Jesus liked to go and of course it
was night Judas knew that Jesus would go
to the Garden of Gethsemane up on the
Mount of Olives and so he directed them
to where Jesus was yeah and he said it's
the one that I kiss right because it's
dark and other disciples around yeah and
they had beards yeah they all started
looking alike after a while
all right well thanks for your call Rita
we've never heard that question before
uh Isabelle listening from Arkansas
Isabel welcome to the program
my name is Isabel and my question is how
do you know when Jesus is speaking to
you
good question Isabel thank you for
calling well
Jesus does speak to us when we read the
Bible
and some Bibles have got red letters
wherever Jesus speaks they call them red
letter editions and when you read the
words of Jesus that's the words of Jesus
speaking to you sometimes God speaks to
you through his holy spirit you know you
might be tempted to say something you
you shouldn't say or get angry or to
disobey your parents well that's the
devil telling you to do the wrong thing
and then Jesus and the Holy Spirit will
say no I want you to do the good thing I
want you to do the right thing that
would be the Lord speaking to you
through his Spirit sometimes God even
speaks to you through pastors when you
go to church and they're preaching a
sermon you'll hear the Holy Spirit speak
to you through the words that they share
and so very rarely
Jesus does talk to a person audibly
personally like he did with Moses and
Abraham and Jacob Samuel Samuel that's
right so yeah when Samuel was just a
little boy he said Samuel Samuel he
spoke to him
so uh but God's voice will always follow
the Bible that's one thing you can be
sure thank you Isabel good question next
father we have is Henry listening from
New York Henry you on the air
Henry are you there you might have your
phone muted
hi and your question
yeah my question
[Music]
most amazing him
if everybody lives in jail who who is
related to him
is there anyone living today related to
Moses or Abraham good question
um you know the the genealogy of Moses
is not as clear as the genealogy of
Abraham who of course is an ancestor of
Moses Moses had two sons they don't ever
seem to rise to prominence they were
from the tribe of Levi it was not Moses
Sons but the sons of Aaron his brother
that ended up being the high priests so
the sons of Moses some of them worked in
the temple with the other Levites but
they're not mentioned and it's hard to
track the family tree of Moses Abraham
on the other hand you can see the
descendants of Abraham around the world
not only in the the nation of Jews but
you can see in the children of Ishmael
many of them became your you know is
what do you call it your Semitic peoples
and Arabs
of course not all Muslims are Arabs I
think the largest group of Muslims in
the world are Indonesia because Islam is
a religion but most Arabs could trace
their genealogy back to Abraham also
thank you appreciate your question Henry
we've got Thomas listening in Oklahoma
Thomas you're on the air welcome to
Bible answers live
yeah I got a question for Revelation 14
12. okay and uh
specifically in the last sentence of the
verse and and the faith of Jesus all
right so it wasn't mean those all right
let me read this for our friends it says
here speaking in Revelation chapter 12
verse 14. here is the patience of the
Saints here are those that keep the
Commandments of God I said that 12 14
section of Revelation 14 12.
here's the patience of the Saints here
are those that keep the Commandments of
God in the faith of Jesus now it's not
saying faith in Jesus here it's saying
the faith of Jesus and so they are
modeling in their lives the faith that
Jesus demonstrated when he was Unearthed
Jesus said I live by the father well we
follow his example and we live by faith
in Christ as he lived by faith in the
father so they have the same kind of
Faith as Jesus is that your yeah
absolutely you know I heard somebody
once put it this way they said faith in
Jesus saves you but the faith of Jesus
sustains you it gives you strength to
overcome to live a Victorious Life and
of course the context here Revelation
chapter 14 it's talking about God's
people in the last days they need to
have the faith of Jesus and they're
being contrasted with counterfeit
Christians and so in the faith of Jesus
not only sustains it identifies you got
the kind of Faith Jesus had yeah very
good all right thank you for your call
Thomas we got Alex listening in Georgia
Alex welcome to the program
hey how are you thank you pastors for
taking my call yes thanks for calling
uh my question
um is when Adam and Eve were in the
garden uh which Commandments did they
break
well God gave us yeah it's okay more
yeah well the lord gave a specific
commandment earlier in Genesis chapter
two he told them that they were free to
eat from any of the trees any and all of
the trees in the garden with one
exception there was one tree that would
be a test of loyalty and he said do not
eat from the tree in the middle of the
Garden of Good and Evil I don't want you
to experience evil they would eat from
the Tree of Life and every other
Pleasant thing in the garden and so when
the serpent when you know the devil kind
of took possession of The Serpent and
the devil said through the serpent oh
you can't really trust God he's trying
to keep something from you if you'd eat
from this forbidden tree you'd have
special powers you'd be like gods look
at me I was a serpent but now I can talk
I'm paraphrasing and um
he cast doubt on God and they chose to
listen to the devil instead of God they
broke the Commandment where God said do
not eat from The Forbidden tree they did
God said the penalty was death for
Disobedience and even if you want to get
a little more specific looking at the
Ten Commandments the Ten Commandment
says Thou shalt not covet the Bible says
Eve looked at the tree she desired the
fruit to make one up wise she took of it
so the first commandment that she broke
was the coveting one she wanted
something that God had said Is Not Yours
she took something that was not herself
yeah she gave it to her husband killed
so you could probably you know you don't
want any other gods ahead of you and she
chose to put what the serpent was saying
ahead of what God was saying so if you
if you look at it like the Bible says if
you break one commandment you're guilty
of breaking all of them at least the
spirit of all of The Commandments so yes
the Ten Commandments were broken in the
garden yeah good question Alex hey thank
you so much for your calling we hope you
call back we've got Michael listening in
Michigan Michael welcome to the program
uh good evening pastors uh I got a
question uh my wife and I are studying
Revelations uh 12-1 it's the woman
clothed with the son and she's the Moon
is under her feet what is the Garland of
12 Stars great I like that we've had
several Revelation questions tonight and
we love it
um in Revelation 12 you've got a picture
first let's figure out who is this woman
and then it helps everything else become
clear the Bible tells us in Bible
symbols that a woman represents a church
Revelation is two women one is clothed
with light sun moon and stars are lights
that God made the others close with kind
of artificial adornment goals and pearls
and purple and Scarlet and costly Ray
but um one is a true faithful bride of
Christ the Bible says husbands love your
wives as Christ loved the church
and God says I've likened the daughter
of Zion to a delicate and comely woman
Zion was a word for God's Church of
liking the church to a woman and Hosea
he says the church is like his bride so
this is a picture of God's pure true
church standing on the sun and that's
Jesus is the son of righteousness that
arises with healing in his wings you
find in Malachi chapter 4 clothed with
the moon she's standing on the promises
and Prophecies of the Old Testament is
the foundation for the New Testament but
she's clothed shining with the light of
Christ's righteousness in the New
Testament 12 stars above the head above
the head represents Authority and you've
got the 12 tribes and 12 judges in the
Old Testament 12 Apostles that's talking
about the leadership
and Revelation chapter is it one he
talks about the stars represent the
angels
of the Church of churches yeah they're
the spokesman the leaders and so you've
got the 12 above her head represents the
the leadership of the church
but more than anything it's the light of
Truth the Sun the moon and stars you
know the word is a lamp to my feet and a
light saying this woman is clothed with
light
and so yeah it's just a picture of the
glory of God's Church you know we've got
to study God it's called the bride of
Christ nothing it actually deals with
Revelation chapter 12. we'll be happy to
send this to anyone who calls and asks
the number again is uh
800-835-6747 that is our free resource
line and just ask for the study guide
It's called the bride of Christ we'll be
happy to send it to anyone who calls and
asks next caller that we have is uh
karise listening from Washington Chris
welcome to the program
hello good night thank you for checking
my call I just got a question from first
John chapter 5 verse 16. could you
please could you please explain that
passage for me yeah well let me read it
for everybody it says in this is first
John 5 verse 16. if anyone sees his
brother sinning a sin that does not lead
to death he will ask and he will give
him Life For Those who commit sin not
leading to death right there it's
telling us of course that we can
intercede and pray for people but then
he goes on and he says there is a sin
leading to death and I do not say he
should pray about that now you would
think well shouldn't we pray for
everybody well you know intercessory
prayer in In This respect is more
effective for people that are willing uh
you've got a sin that is leads to death
that prayer won't even help and that
would be the sin against the Holy Spirit
an unpardonable sin I think also when it
talks about a sin not leading to death I
think it's also talking about praying
for those who might be sinning
ignorantly yeah so you know Jesus prayed
on the cross said father forgive them
for they do not know what they are doing
as referring to the Roman soldiers are
probably just carrying out their orders
and so there are people that have never
heard the truth and they might not be
doing what is right or maybe they don't
know maybe they are sinning ignorance
but there are those who have hardly
hearted as you said that Sunday cannot
be forgiven which is the unpardonable
sin and they are sinning willfully
you know we want to pray for everyone
but there is a difference there is sins
of ignorance and then there's deliberate
high-handed Rebellion against God
that's right so I hope that helps a
little bit courtesy yes
all right thank you Cole we've got uh
Anastasia listening in Canada Anastasia
welcome to the program
hello hi how can we help you tonight hi
Patrick yeah
um I actually had two very quick
questions if you can answer them both
um so my first one is
um in the Bible it says that um love
casts out all fear right but if you're a
person living with OCD and let's just
say you like for me I always have to be
like washing my hands and everything
like that because I'm scared of germs
um am I like not going with God's law by
doing that
no well
let me answer you with something more
than just a yes or a no
um
I empathize with you a little bit
because I am a little OCD now I I don't
want to trivialize what you're going
through because some people it just
obsessively you know washing their hands
but if you ask my wife I'm a little
compulsive that way where you know I go
around through the day washing my hands
probably did it 20 times today it's not
that I'm afraid of germs I mean you know
you know me Pastor I said I'm not
obsessed with germs it's just that uh
Pastor Doug likes clean uh yeah I am
you're driving his car it's it's always
clean I am a little that way yes and so
I get a little bit agitated if things
aren't in the right place and and uh you
know but you're asking a bigger question
about anxiety and fear am I right and uh
Anastasia and you're just wondering does
it mean I have a lack of faith that I'm
I'm worrying about these things well no
because I think that you're addressing
something that you you can't control
you're trying not to feel that way right
right yes yes yeah so uh you know I
expect you're trying to maybe get some
Christian Counsel on the subject so that
you can get some some relief and uh I
wrote a book that you might find some
comfort in and it's called finding peace
in a world of worry
and I partly wrote this because I can
sometimes have a tendency to worry and I
know a lot of people that are just sick
with worry and I found a lot of comfort
in just writing the book and looking at
all the scriptures and the promises
about worry
and we live in the world I said like
that's just a masters look at the news
and yeah it causes alarm and worry and
with the news in the last two years
about germs and covet everywhere that
could make some people a little bit
apprehensive and you know just wash your
hands all the time
so I wouldn't call it a sin I pray that
God would just give you some peace and
balance uh you know I think God wants us
to be clean but he doesn't want us to be
obsessive so that you know you just
can't live your life because you're
always having to run for a sanitizer
um it's amazing any of us survive
childhood we're eating you know six
pounds of dirt every year but uh anyway
so you might enjoy that book you can
call and ask for finding peace in a
world of worry and I bet they'll send
you a copy for free number to call these
800-835-6747 and again the book's called
finding peace in a world of worry we've
got Chris listening in North Carolina
Chris welcome to the program
hi good evening pastors how are you
doing great good
wonderful um I was just a real quick
question
um I know during creation uh during the
time of Adam and Eve
that there was a war that broke out in
heaven between Lucifer and Michael but
how long or what period of time was uh
Satan on Earth during that time
well we don't believe that Satan came to
Earth until of course after the creation
of Adam and Eve which happened after the
Rebellion we believe and you know you're
not going to find a lot of explicit
scriptures on the timetable for this but
we did a lot of study on the subject
before we did a special documentary
called Cosmic conflict the origin of sin
and by the way that documentary you can
just see it on YouTube now called Cosmic
conflict
we understand that one of the reasons
God made our world in humanity is to
help replace the vacuum from Satan and
his angels being cast out following
their rebellion in that war you read
about the war there in Revelation 12.
Revelation 12 of course is looking back
in time to the war between Michael and
Satan the devil so am I answering your
question Chris
yes kind of yes I just was wondering how
long he was when he was cast down to
earth what period of time he was down
here for because we know after Adam and
Eve were created that the devil was cast
to Earth yeah and he's still here
he's alive and well as they say you know
this just to add to that little bit past
it in chapter 12 it talks about this war
in heaven Michael and his angels are
cast out so you have a casting out now
Michael and his angels fought against
the dragon and the dragon and these
Angels were cast out so before the
creation of the earth there's this war
in heaven the devil and his angels
rebellion of course they are cast out of
heaven but you read a little further in
Revelation chapter 12 and it says at
some point the devil was cast to the
Earth
so the casting up and casting down
didn't happen at the same time but when
Christ died on the cross Satan's Doom
was fixed and Jesus became the
representative of the earth he is the
second Adam yeah so the Bible says the
devil has about a short time he's going
around like a roaring lion so he is sort
of bound to this earth he doesn't have
freedom to roam the universe and then
after the 1000 or during the 1000 years
it's just him and his angels on the
earth they've got nobody to tend so and
Jesus said I beheld Satan cast down as
Lightning yeah so falling as lightning
from Heaven he helped affect that next
caller that we have is uh Dalton
listening in Texas Dalton welcome to the
program
well hello and thank you all for uh
having such a good program well it's a
pleasure thank you
yes uh my question is and I hate to ask
it it's about the Book of Enoch why is
it uh
why don't we use it or why don't we
reference it yeah
that's a fair question because in the
book of Jude which is in the Bible Jude
quotes from The Book of Enoch which is
not in the Bible
and that because a Bible writer quotes
from a book does not mean that
everything in the book they quoted from
is original or inspired
for example Paul quotes from some of the
Greek poets
and they said some things were true and
he quoted from those excerpts well there
was a book called The Book of Enoch that
was probably written during the
Babylonian captivity by some of the Jews
and it's it's what they call an
apocryphal book and it had some
statements in it that were inspired
statements but the whole book wasn't
necessarily inspired and you know many
times pastors I I do it I'm sure you do
and I might quote Martin Luther quote
Spurgeon or Wesley or you know other
great preachers and there's certain
things they said that are very profound
maybe even inspired
went to some things Lutheran Luther said
I know we're not inspired you know I
mean Luther said some pretty harsh
things about the Jewish people and uh I
think most Christians disavow themselves
of those things that he he said so but
that I that wanted uh undermine or take
away from the inspired things that he
did say and how God used him
and so same thing with the Book of Enoch
anyone can download a copy of the Book
of Enoch you can read it you'll see that
there's some stuff in there that's
obviously not scriptural but it was
probably written by a or a Jew or a
couple of Jews during the Babylonian
captivity it did not come with Noah
across the flood from Enoch it's never
mentioned anywhere in history prior to
the time after the Babylonian captivity
so
all right great I think uh next call is
Hector listening from Florida hecto
Welcome to the program
Hector you're on the air thank you
yes thank you uh good evening everyone
how did you survive the hurricane
are you in Southern Florida
no yeah I'm a homestead area so we
didn't talk too much okay
that's it yeah
um I have a question on uh chapter 22 of
the Revelation yeah
um specifically uh verse 2 and 15.
okay let me read this it says revelation
22 verse 2 in the middle of the street
and on either side of the river was the
tree of life that had 12 different kinds
of fruit each tree yielding its fruit
every month and the leaves of the tree
are for the healing of the Nations so
what you want to do that first
right let's do that uh my question
specifically uh is an enlarged sentence
and you say the least of the three uh
well for the healing of the nation and
when you know the kingdom of God
what have pain and sickness and diseases
yeah stuff like that and also uh
everybody would be one nation but now in
this world it's mentioned Nations and
plural will be multiple Nations you know
oh well let me we're going to run out of
time so let me answer that real quick
um you notice it's it's not talking
about the healing of diseases
it's the healing of Nations we are
divided now in the world by political
parties and Nations and cultures and
geography in the Kingdom all those
divisions will be healed As We Gather
under the shimmering leaves of the tree
of life we will all be part of one
people and won't have to worry hey I'm
sorry I can't give you more of an answer
than that Dalton we need to let our
listening friends know we sign off from
Bible answers live sort of in two stages
because the time schedules with
satellite radio first we sign off with
our listeners that are listening on
SiriusXM and then our land-based
stations so we want to bid farewell to
the people listening on satellite those
of you who are on the land base stations
you stay tuned because this is when we
take our email questions that come in
we'll be back and do some Rapid File
rapid fire email
thank you for listening to today's
broadcast we hope you understand your
Bible even better than before Bible
answers live is produced by amazing
facts International a faith-based
Ministry located in Granite Bay
California
Hello friends welcome back to Bible
answers live for those of you have been
able to stay by those watching on the
internet listening on land-based radio
stations if you have a Bible question
and you want to email it to us the email
address is just
b-a-lquestions
amazingfacts.org in Pasad we're going to
see how many of these questions we can
get in the next two minutes so here's
the first question when the body dies
where does the spirit go
well the Bible tells us that what we
call the spirit is uh you know or
sometimes referred to as the soul it's
the combination of that Breath of Life
which is the word Spirit and the body
the word spirit in Greek is the word
pneuma that's where you get the word
pneumonia means a wind and so the idea
that you've got a ghost that flies out
of you when you die is not what the
Bible teaches you cease being a soul
until the resurrection when the Breath
of Life is United again with the new
creation the new body okay next question
that we have how do we know if we are
walking in the spirit
yeah
well Jesus said you will know them by
their fruits and so you know we can
examine ourselves I believe it's in
second Corinthians chapter 13. there the
Apostle Paul said let us examine
ourselves whether we be in the faith and
we use the criteria of Christ his
example his teachings and say Lord am I
am I walking in the spirit do I have
that peace that he offers am I living in
communion with God and you will have the
fruits of the spirit
okay another question uh Revelation
chapter 21 4 says that God will wipe
away every tear from their eyes when
does this occur
yeah people sometimes think that as soon
as you go to heaven there could possibly
be No More Tears in Heaven but it really
doesn't say that God wipes away all the
tears until after the millennium because
at the end of the Millennium there is a
great white Throne judgment many are
found lost in that judgment and people
might have friends or family that are
not there and you know God
is sad if angels rejoice when someone's
saved then presumably their sadness when
someone's lost if they have those
emotions then we have those emotions but
after God makes the Earth new following
the 1000 years that's when it says he
wipes away all tears from our eyes all
right Pastor like a quick question here
what type of locusts did John the
Baptist eat
yeah was it locust bean the same word is
used for the Locust pod something like
our carapod or was it the Grasshoppers
we don't know we're hoping it was the
locust bean because we hate to picture
the prophet with Grasshopper legs in his
teeth hey listening friends we hope that
you will tune in and join us again next
week send us your Bible questions keep
the ministry in prayer and support us to
keep doing what we're doing
Bible answers live honest and accurate
answers to your Bible questions
[Music]